>> Laura: THE MAJOR MEDIA ARE
SELECTIVELY REPORTING THE FBI
AND DOJ BRIEFING OF KEY
LAWMAKERS LAST WEEK ABOUT THAT
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
WHILE TYPICAL OF TODAY'S
SCREAMING HEADLINES, ABC BLARED
GAUDI DISPUTES THE TRUMP SPY
CLAIM AND SAYS FBI ACTED
PROPERLY.
BUT THAT IGNORES A NUMBER OF KEY
POINTS THAT OVERSIGHT CHAIR
GAUDI MADE ON FOX GLIDE LAST
NIGHT.
THE FIRST WAS THAT THE DOJ MADE
CLEAR THAT TRUMP WAS NOT AND IS
NOT A TARGET OF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
HE COULD NOT ALSO EXPLAIN WHY
THE FBI COULD NOT DO THAT
DEFENSIVE BRIEFING OF THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN INSTEAD OF RELYING ON A
FORM IT INSIDE THE CAMPAIGN.
FORMER FEDERAL PROSECUTOR ANDY
McCARTHY LAID OUT HIS THEORY.
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT
THEY SPIED ON THE CAMPAIGN.
IF YOU WERE LOOKING AT A
CORPORATION AND THEY THOUGHT THE
CORPORATION WAS CORRUPTED BY
THREE PEOPLE, YOU GO TO THE CEO
AND YOU SAY, I THINK WE HAVE A
PROBLEM HERE.
BUT THEY DIDN'T SAID INSTEAD WAS
SEND COVERT OPERATIVES TO PRY
INFORMATION OUT.
>> Laura: THAT'S WHY THEY WERE
UNHAPPY THAT GAUDI KIND OF MUDDY
THE WATERS.
ONE OF THEM IS DAN BONGINO OF
NRA TV, AND ALSO JOINING US IS
DANIEL GOLDMAN, FORMER ASSISTANT
ATTORNEY FOR THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT OF NEW YORK.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE BOTH OF YOU.
DAN BONGINO, FIRST.
LET'S GO TO YOU.
WE INVITED GAUDI ON THE SHOW,
AND WE WANT HIM TO COME ON
BECAUSE HE'S A VERY SMART GUY.
KIND OF CONFUSING HOW HE COMES
ACROSS, BUT WHERE DO YOU COME
DOWN ON SPECIFICALLY WHAT HE
SAID ABOUT THE SPYGATE
SITUATION?
>> APPEARANCE IS NOW BEING USED
AS PROPAGANDA BY THE LEFT, AND
WHAT HE SAID WAS SO COMPLETELY
OUT OF LINE AND FACTUALLY
INCORRECT.
LAURA, LET'S RUN THROUGH SOME
BASIC FACTS.
SO THE FBI RENTED BY THE BOOK,
THE WAY AMERICANS WANTED HIM TO
RUN THE INVESTIGATION.
REALLY?
THEN WHY DIDN'T THEY NOTIFY
CONGRESS ABOUT -- FOR EIGHT
MONTHS, WHEN PRIOR PROCEDURE WAS
TO NOTIFY CONGRESS QUARTERLY ON
SENSITIVE INVESTIGATIONS.
ANOTHER QUESTION.
IF THEY RAN IT BY THE BOOK, HOW
IS IT THAT TWO SUSPICIOUS
POTENTIALLY FELONY WEEKS OF
INFORMATION HAPPENED IN BOTH
OCTOBER AND JANUARY TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND
"WASHINGTON POST"?
IS THAT AN EXAMPLE, MR. GOWDY,
OF A FINELY TUNED INVESTIGATION
RUN THE WAY AMERICANS WOULD HAVE
WANTED, HIDDEN FROM CONGRESS?
HE DID NOTHING BUT FEED THE
LEFTIST PROPAGANDA MACHINE
YESTERDAY AND HE SHOULD GO BACK
AND CLARIFY THOSE OUT
OUTRAGEOUS, ABSURD REMARKS.
>> Laura: I THINK HE'S
OBSESSING OVER THE DEFINITION OF
SPY WITHIN THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE VERSUS AN INFORMANT IN
AN ONGOING INVESTIGATION, WHICH
I THINK IS BEYOND THE POINT.
I WANT TO PLAY FOR YOU A
SOUND BITE FROM FROM JASON
CHAFFETZ.
>> IF JEFF SESSIONS IS THERE IN
NAME ONLY, IS ABSOLUTELY
WORTHLESS.
THE SOONER THE PRESIDENT NEEDS A
NEW ATTORNEY GENERAL, THE
BETTER.
HE SHOULD HAVE NEVER RECUSED
HIMSELF, HE NEVER NEEDED TO ANY
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE OPERATION.
>> Laura: THIS IS OF COURSE
REGARDING THE TRUMP TWEET TODAY,
COMMENTING ON WHAT GOWDY DID SAY
WHICH MANY OF US TOOK NOTE OF,
WHICH IS, YOU COULD HAVE THAT IN
A TOP LAWYER BE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
MEANWHILE, YOU PICK A GUY WHO
EVERYONE LIKES BUT RECUSED
HIMSELF RIGHT OFF THE BAT.
FOR REACTION?
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT SHOULD
DO HIS HOMEWORK A LITTLE BIT
MORE BECAUSE THIS WAS AN OBVIOUS
RECUSAL UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE REGULATION.
IT SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN A
SURPRISE TO HIM OR HIS LAWYERS.
SO THE FACT THAT HE THEN
ANNOUNCED THAT HE WAS RECUSING
HIMSELF, BECAUSE HE WAS AN
INTEGRAL PLAYER IN THE CAMPAIGN
AND THEREFORE COULD NOT OVERSEE
AN INVESTIGATION INTO THE
CAMPAIGN SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN A
SURPRISE.
THE OTHER PROBLEM THAT I SEE AS
A FORMER FEDERAL PROSECUTOR
ABOUT THE WAY THAT TRUMP VIEWS
SESSIONS AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL IS HE SEEMS TO BE
TALKING A LOT ABOUT WANTING
SOMEONE WHO IS LOYAL TO HIM.
WHICH, ON ITS FACE IS FINE, HE
GETS TO CHOOSE HIS CABINET, AND
I GET THAT.
BUT WHAT HE IS REALLY INDICATING
AND EMPLOYING AND MAKING THAT
STATEMENT IS THAT YOU WANT
SOMEONE LOYAL TO HIM AT THE TOP
OF THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WHO
WILL SQUASH AN INVESTIGATION
INTO EITHER HIM, OR HIS
CAMPAIGN, ASSOCIATES, CHILDREN,
OR WHATEVER YOU HAVE.
>> Laura: WAIT A SECOND.
WAS ERIC HOLDER PERCEIVED TO BE
LOW
LOYAL TO BARACK OBAMA?
I THINK YOU COULD ARGUE THAT
ERIC HOLDER WENT ABOVE AND
BEYOND WHAT THE LEFT IS NOW
SAYING THAT TRUMP SHOULD NOW
HAVE THE RELATIONSHIP WITH
SESSIONS.
SO I THINK THAT LOYALTY WENT
REALLY DEEP BETWEEN THE TWO OF
THEM, WHETHER IT WAS THE IRS
INVESTIGATION, HOW THEY HANDLED
FAST AND FURIOUS, HOW THEY DID
THE ROADS AND OVERSIGHT, WHETHER
THE PRESIDENT KNEW ANYTHING
ABOUT THIS AND WHETHER THEY WERE
EVER BRIEFED ON IT.
YOU COULDN'T GET INFORMATION OUT
OF THESE PEOPLE SO I THINK
LOYALTY MATTERED TO OBAMA OFF
THE TOP OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
>> I THINK LOYALTY IN SOME
RESPECTS MATTERS.
>> THE PRESIDENTS WING MAN,
THAT'S WHAT HE CALLED HIMSELF.
>> WHILE I DON'T KNOW BUT WHEN
TRUMP IS SAYING THAT HE WANTS
LOYALTY, AS A FORMER ORGANIZED
CRIME PROSECUTOR, I HEAR
SOMETHING VERY DIFFERENT THAN
WANTING SOMEONE WHO IS CLOSE TO
HIM, WHO IS LOYAL TO HIM.
THE CRITICAL DIFFERENCE THAT I
THINK YOU HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE,
BOTH OF YOU, IS THAT
BARACK OBAMA WAS NOT UNDER
INVESTIGATION BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
SO WHETHER YOU LIKE IT OR NOT,
DAN, HE IS UNDER INVESTIGATION.
SO YOU HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
INVESTIGATION INTO THE PRESIDENT
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
>> Laura: WHILE HE IS ALSO THE
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH, OF THE
GOVERNMENT.
AND THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER,
SO IF HE WANTED TO, HE COULD
FIRE ANYONE HE WANTS.
IS IT POLITICALLY APPROPRIATE?
I THINK DANIEL GOLDMAN'S RIGHT,
IT WOULDN'T BE POLITICALLY
APPROPRIATE TO DO THAT.
BUT IF HE WANTED TO GET RID OF
COMEY, OR ROSENSTEIN WHO WAS A
DISASTER FROM THE BEGINNING, HE
COULD GET RID OF THEM.
WE COULD GET RID OF SESSIONS IF
HE WANTED.
>> WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THOUGH IS
HE IS COMPLETELY ABOVE THE LAW
AND HE COULD FIRE ANYBODY FOR
CORRUPT PRACTICES.
>> DAN, YOU ARE JUST MAKING
STUFF UP NOW AND I WISH SHE
WOULD STOP DOING THAT.
YOU SAID BEFORE THAT, THE
PRESIDENT IS LOOKING FOR SOMEONE
TO QUASH THESE INVESTIGATIONS.
I'M GUESSING YOU ARE NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THE DETAILS OF THE
CASE BECAUSE, IT'S ALREADY OPEN
SOURCE THAT THE PRESIDENT SAID
MULTIPLE TIMES THAT IF THERE WAS
A RUSSIAN INTELLIGENCE ASSET IN
HIS CAMPAIGN TRYING TO
COMPROMISE HIS CAMPAIGN, HE
WANTS TO KNOW ABOUT IT.
SO, DAN, YOU MAY BE HEARING THIS
FOR THE FIRST TIME AND I WILL
GIVE YOU THE CHANCE TO RETRACT
THAT.
BUT WHO QUASH IS AN
INVESTIGATION WELL ASKING THE
FBI SIMULTANEOUSLY TO
INVESTIGATE THAT.
I WILL WAIT FOR YOUR ANSWER.
>> Laura: I THINK HE WANTED TO
BE FAIR AND HE WANTS AN
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO DOESN'T
MELT WHEN "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
EDITORIAL BOARD GETS UPSET ABOUT
A RECUSAL THAT HE NEVER HAD TO
DO.
I THINK THAT'S PROBABLY WHAT HE
WANTS AND WHAT MOST PRESIDENTS
WANT.
>> HE HAD TO DO IT UNDER THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
REGULATIONS.
>> Laura: NO HE DIDN'T.
BECAUSE -- WHAT DID HE HAVE TO
DO WITH RUSSIAN COLLUSION?
HE HAD ZERO TO DO WITH IT.
I THINK IT WAS CONVENIENT.
>> I THINK IT HAD TO DO WITH IT
THE FACT THAT HE WAS AN INTEGRAL
PART OF THE CAMPAIGN AND THE
CAMPAIGN WAS A SUBJECT TO
INVESTIGATION.
>> Laura: WAS STARTED WITH A
RIDICULOUS INFORMANT WHO WAS
TROLLING FOR GOD ONLY KNOWS WHAT
AND MONEY.
>> HOW DO YOU KNOW THAT?
>> Laura: YOU ARE SAYING JEFF
SESSIONS WAS INTEGRALLY
INVOLVED.
THAT WAS A PRUDENTIAL DECISION
THAT HE MADE AND I WOULD SAY --
I DON'T THINK IT WAS REQUIRED AT
ALL.
>> ALL RIGHT, READ THE RAGS,
THEY ARE VERY CLEAR.
>> Laura: HOW MANY OF THE
OBAMA PEOPLE EVER RECUSED
THEMSELVES, RARELY IF EVER?
>> YES BUT OBAMA WAS NEVER
INVESTIGATED.
I'M JUST SAYING TO YOU IF THERE
IS A CONFIDENTIAL INFORMANT THAT
HAS INFORMATION OF WRONGDOING IN